there's been a lot of Buzz about how the
diabetes drug metformin could help
people live longer results are mixed on
metformin's actual efficacy as an
anti-aging treatment One Way metformin
is supposed to help with anti-aging is
by activating a cellular process called
autophagy it literally means self-eating
your cells do this all the time to keep
themselves and you healthy let's go over
how autophagy works and its role in
aging think of autophagy as your cells
recycling system cells use autophagy to
get rid of proteins and other cellular
components that aren't working properly
or could cause problems this process
goes a little something like this little
sacs and Gulf proteins and structures
like mitochondria the powerhouses of
cells these sacs Infuse with another
cellular compartment called the lysosome
think of it as a cell Shredder the sax
cargo gets broken down there by enzymes
in the lysosome
and cells can then reuse these materials
to build new stuff that makes autophagy
protective against aging and stress in
two ways it provides cells with energy
especially when food is low and it
prevents junk from piling up but as we
age autophagy levels go down and the
Damage our bodies accumulate at the
cellular level goes up
longevity experts think the damage
buildup is one of the main reasons we
age damage can happen even from basic
functions like breathing and
metabolizing food kind of like when we
burn fuel in our cars these reactions
can produce tiny pollutants that can
cause inflammation and harm proteins and
mitochondria over time there's too much
damage or not enough repair and cells
just don't work as well as when they
were younger in worst case scenario they
die that's why certain diseases become
more common with age for diabetes
impaired autophagy is associated with
insulin resistance a Hallmark of the
disease and in some types of dementia
brain cells that can't get rid of
protein comes through autophagy they die
by promoting autophagy the goal is to
increase health span or the amount of
time we can live a healthy life free of
debilitating age-related conditions like
dementia and diabetes and if lifespan is
extended too all the better since
metformin helps increase autophagy that
might mean it also helps prevent
cellular damage and therefore aging
there are other drugs and methods that
can boost autophagy Resveratrol is an
anti-tumor drum that's also a powerful
antioxidant and rapamycin is an
immunosuppressant that's been shown to
extend lifespan in animals kind of like
metformin some longevity experts are
also looking at intermittent fasting
there's already preliminary evidence
that it promotes brain health when you
don't eat autophagy increases to fill
the energy void if you're interested in
the health effects of fasting check out
this other video I made in mice research
suggests that increased autophagy allows
them to live longer and their organs to
age less quickly but that doesn't always
translate to humans sometimes doses that
are used in animal studies are way
higher than what people can take safely
plus taking any medication has side
effects format foramen those include a
higher risk of Parkinson's disease and
difficulty building muscle mass
potentially because of too much
autophagy and in transplant patients who
take rapamycin more frequently and at
higher doses than longevity biohackers
common side effects can include mouth
ulcers loss of kidney function and high
blood pressure and high cholesterol
levels understanding how people age and
why some people age better than others
could help us develop better anti-aging
therapies and that's critical given the
world's population is aging fast
foreign